hello in this video i explain to you
what the prerequisites for a linear
regression are and how you can
easily check them online and with that
we start right away the
prerequisites for the linear
regression are there must be a
linear connection between the dependent and
the independent variable  the
error epson must be normally distributed
there must be no multipolarity
this would mean that the
recession equation is unstable
there must be no
heterogeneous activity the variance of the reside
must be constant over the entire predicted
value range and so
we start now and go into the
individual  points in more detail and
finally I will show you how you
can check the prerequisites online and
so we will start with the
linearity in the line region
a straight line is laid through the data
this straight line should depict all points as well as possible
there is a non-linear relationship
between  the dependent  igen and the
independent variable, this can
not fulfill the task
. Let's look at these two
graphics. The first graphic
has a nice linear
connection between dependent variables and the
independent variable. Here, the
recession can be placed in the
points
In the second case, however, since there is a
clear non-never relationship
between the dependent and the
independent variable, it is not
possible to put a registration
straight into the points in
be interpreted or there
may be errors in the prediction that
are larger than expected,
so it must always be checked at the beginning
whether there is a linear
connection between the dependent and the
respective independent variable.
this is usually done graphically,
the next one ahead  the requirement is that the
error apps i lon
must be normally distributed to check this there are two
ways, the analytical way
and the graphical
way, either the
kolmakov smirnow test or the schapiro
work test can be used for the analytical way is the p
value  greater than 0.05 there is no
deviation of the data from the
normal distribution, so one can
assume that the data is normally distributed
, however, these analytical
tests are used less and less,
so the graphic variant is used more and more
with the graphic variant,
either the histogram is looked at or
still  the better
the so-called coco plot or quantity
, the more the deeds are on the line
, the better the
normal distribution
and this brings us to
homosexuality. a prerequisite
for linear regression is that the
residents have a constant variance,
so a region model is
never used in practice  exactly 1 dependent variable
before  you can say
you always have an error now you can
flatten your dependent variable on the x-
axis and an error on the y-axis
homosexuality now means that your
error is constant over the entire range
if the result looks like this
then there is no homogeneity  in that
case we have different error
variants depending on which
prediction area we are in. it must be in
which area we are from dependent
variables  namely that there
must be no multipolarity
multi culinary activity means that two or
more independent variables
correlate strongly with one another
the problem with multipolarity is that
the effect of individual variables cannot be
clearly separated
let's look at the
recession equation again for this
we have the dependent variable here
and here we have the independent  important
variables such as a high correlation
between x1 and x2 or if these
two variables are almost the same
then it is difficult to determine b1 and b2
are both, for example,
completely the same knows that the repression
model is not how large and b1 and
b2 should
be  recession model then becomes unstable
in mathematics one speaks of
an over-determined equation system
one wants to use the recession model for
a prediction it doesn't matter
if multi-core linearity is present in
a prediction one is only interested in
how good the prediction is but
one is interested  not what
influence which variable has on the
dependent variable, however, the
recession model is used to measure
the influence of the independent variable
on the dependent variable
, multi-quality must not be present,
then it is present, the coefficients
cannot be meaningfully interpreted, how
can one multiculturalism
diagnose
s  let's look again at the government
same can then we have the
variable x1 x2 up to 6 k we
now want to know whether x1 is quite identical to
any other variable
or a combination of the
other variables for this we set
up a new recession model in
this  new recession model,
we take x1 as the new dependent variable if
we can
now very well infer x1 with the other independent variables
, it means that we can make the same
statement that we can make with x1
with the other variables
if we use the other
independent ones  variables can now very well
infer x1, it means that we can make
the same statement that we can make with x1
with the other
variables, so x1 is
more or less superfluous and
may make the recession model
unstable
if you e.g  other
variables can then put together
the recession model  don't know
what b1 is or what the other
coefficients should be, then
our equation system would be determined via
this we can now do for all other
variables, so we estimate x2
depending on the other variables
and we now estimate xk depending
on the other variables  can
we calculate the so-called tolerance and the value for all new recession models in
this case recession models the
tolerance results from
1 - the certainty requirement of the variance
on
again as a reminder the variance
explanation indicates how much of the variance
of x1 is explained by the other variables
the more that is
the more likely one speaks of
multipolarity because we
actually want each individual
variable to have as little to do with others as possible
if the tolerance is below
0.1 you have to be careful and there could be
multipolarity
on the other side  do we still have the
value of the value calculate  t is divided by 1
through the tolerance accordingly you have to
be careful if this value is greater than
ten so and now i will show you
how you can easily
check this requirement online here for visitors
day.de and click on the statistics
calculator if
you want your own  use
data just click on the table
teacher
i use the at plays we
want to calculate a regression so
we just click on repression
let’s just take
the income as the dependent variable and
the age and weight of a person as the independent variable
now we see here  Below are the results,
but we want to check the prerequisites
, so we simply click here
on Check prerequisites,
first of all, we see the prerequisite
that linearity must be present Here
you can see the results for your
variables, you can see whether age has
a linear relationship with
income and  whether the weight has a linear
relationship  with the income
you can also see here whether the error
component is normally distributed for this it is
best to look on the golf course
then you will see the results for the
multipolarity in this table you can see
the tolerance and in wolf values ​​as
I said the tolerance should ideally be above
0  ,0 1 1 or the vip value is less than 10
and here the heterogeneity is
checked in this you get his
forecast applied to the
djs here there should be a constant variance over the entire
range, which we have not yet considered in
this tutorial on the recession
have are
therefore variables so you have to use variables if you want to
use categorical variables
with more than two characteristics as
independent variables
is therefore I continue with
my video about the variables to see you soon